both quarters underwear Ralph Lollar Dom
McClane happy to have you along it was
Saturday afternoon Harris firing right
open look
[Applause]
Oh
maybe though he passed into the game
there by Lou Williams
[Music]
and Lily Williams one of the best in the
league you do not call timeouts so that
the other team can gameplan for you guys
like Lou Williams are so good they can
just figure it out on the flats exactly
what he did put the clock all the way
down and when you're a shot maker like
you William George here it's just fine
for you to take that shot basically at
the buzzer to win the game
not many guys make that shot Lou
Williams is one of them to take that
shot basically it's a buzzer to win the
game not many guys make that shot Lou
Williams is one of them
here is the mind a little again stupid
[Applause]
he says remember me guys Harrell will
draw the personal foul Lou Williams does
a lot of his score to close the game
inside the two-minute mark any overtime
that's just an amazing John Koeppen he
is unbelievable Ralph McKinney's
fallen-down he runs into him and flips
it in the crazy John
the hand-eye coordination on guys like
Lou Williams is never never allow
himself for a wide-open three will
Williams all over the hallway there
Williams show is in full display Diddy
went to the locker room we're gonna try
to update that with Raj we'll see what
is problem eyes Williams on the move
jump shot mid-range shot by Lou Williams
right now it's got to be high screen and
roll Harold Williams this is how they
close games out
my preceptor 14 now
[Applause]
defended by farms and a pretty
[Applause]
twenty nine feet away and he gives his
team the lead for the seconds to go